good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday welcome
to our new timeslot here at the morning
toast it's noon the day's half over whoo
you can start drinking in like an hour I
have to be honest I feel the exact same
but now it feels like daylight savings
time because nothing for me has really
changed I kind of followed my same
morning routine instead now it's noon
o'clock and by the time we're done it's
gonna be 1 o'clock which is just it's
throwing my biological clock off but I'm
here for it because I actually do feel
more rested like I woke up this morning
and I got to like lay in bed on my phone
before I had to like run and get dressed
yeah there's usually a whole host of
things I will do after the toasts like
clean answer emails and I did all that
this morning so I feel like when I get
back I'm gonna get Theo he's gonna take
a nice little beep be outside and then
the day is like 3 o'clock and now that I
have a new found relationship with white
claw I feel like the evenings gonna be
different it's gonna be lit I had like a
renaissance if you will on Saturday
night my first time ever drinking white
cloth which is so crazy because like
what have I been doing if not drinking
my claws and it was um it was pretty
sensational I'm not gonna lie like
they're really delicious and the app
minibar have you ever used it and not
recently yet but I have I've used it and
I mean rate yeah during quarantine it's
really coming in clutch I don't know if
it is available in every city but in New
York it's basically like seamless
delivery but just for alcohol and I
decided to get white claws and the there
was a mixup at the liquor store and
instead of giving me a multipack they
accidentally I guess they ran out cuz
they're so busy I'm sure they gave me
individual white claws like 12 in a bag
instead but they didn't have any regular
sizes so I got like the 40 ounce huge
ones and they're all gone Wow yeah it
was sensational I'm really a black
cherry girl but I could be persuaded to
being a mango girl he like depending on
the vibe
both sound great honestly yeah I think
I'm glad that you have taken the plunge
into drinking in your house because as
someone like who drinks there's no
reason why you shouldn't drink in your
house so I'm rich ever you had your
walls helping or being guarded about
like you had all these preconceived
notions big-time and I'm so glad to see
that like mines are being opened I mean
no one had more walls up than me yet I
would never work out in my house and
then I literally bought a pallet on and
you should hear me going off amazing my
life except I pulled my side yesterday
giving myself a pedicure not from the
Palatine I pull my side from crouching
over to get myself a pedicure also I
gave myself a manicure it looks good I
think it looks really good I'm loving it
was fully influenced by this image and
she's the most influential [ __ ] on the
planet yes and I did the two different
hands and I'm like love these are my two
favorite colors and I know now I don't
have to choose by the way I'm totally
gonna do my own name I'm actually in the
room and you know what's funny I've
tried to do my own nails before when I
was just feeling lazy and they came out
like [ __ ] but it's crazy what you can do
when you absolutely have to necessity is
the mother of invention
like I knew I couldn't get a manicure
like this was it for me and I pulled it
out but when I was just born in my
apartment I was like maybe I'll do it
maybe I will and then the next day I
just went and got a real manicure well I
just think that we used to have all
these walls up but now things have
changed so much but it's because I don't
think either one of us really genuinely
thought that this was gonna last this
long so if it was like a two-week
quarantine I would be like okay I'm not
going to try and I'm gonna do my own
nails but like now that it's looking
like a lifestyle change it's really now
the president said yesterday we're might
return to normalcy in June like this is
our life now so you have to commit we
are mole women like at first it's like
denial you know you get kidnapped as a
mole women and you think like I'm gonna
get out of here eventually and then so
much time passes you realize no no
you're never had to get out the best of
the situation this is your life this is
our life now you want to have ugly nails
and be you know out of shape fine but no
it's not sustainable like week one I
thought this was like a fun little
vacation like oh we're all staying home
and I was like shoving my face and then
it's like you know what would be worse
than being in quarantine for two months
being in quarantine for two months the
doors are open two months later and I
feel so terrible baths way that I look
that I won't even go out that would be
worse yesterday it was really really
setting in for me like how much I took
for granted so many little joys in life
and of course this is not the reasoning
but I think that a lesson can be learned
here like how many you know dinner
parties I just turned down and you know
galas and events I just said no to life
and that was actually a resolution of
mine was to say no to life and spend
more time at home and don't get me wrong
home is fabulous but it can
only it can only take you so far and I
think after this I will and probably not
but I'm thinking that I will have a new
zest for life I will have a new lease on
life 100% 100% yeah I think about like
the little you know I used to feel like
if I went out to dinner at a restaurant
and they made me wait for a table like
it was the biggest inconvenience like to
me it was the worst thing in the world
and I'm just thinking now like how much
money I would give to just be waiting
for a table at like a crowded bar like I
don't even get a seat at the bar and how
you just have to be fabulous and be in
society and oh I'm out of restaurants
that's busy how cool for me yeah and I
think that we all like no matter what
stage in life you are like at some point
we've taken like the simple things for
granted like not that I ever wanted to
but like going for a walk like I would
love to mom I still I'm not there yet
give me another week but like just the
little things like I just feel like I
turned down so many fun opportunities
because I just wanted to stay home cuz
I've always been like a homebody and now
I'm thinking like I wish I went on all
those trips and really what's getting me
in my feelings about this is I've caught
up on so much um
reality TV this week and just the little
things that they do like Gigi and res
that we're going to dinner they like got
drunk look that looks so fun and then
the real houses of Atlanta or in Greece
I'm like you know due to be on a girls
trip in Greece anything I wouldn't get
in perspective absolutely anything yeah
even what like now some things on shows
like just people doing the smallest
riggings it's triggering it's it really
is I hear you so I don't know when this
is all gonna end but mark my words when
it's over like you will not see me like
I am out I'd love to see that I might
even like you know get on a city bag
like I just want to try new things it's
being of citibike been you know mayor de
Blasio is like number one you know hater
was in bed this morning the second he
woke up like someone sent him an
interview that I think Jake Tapper did
on CNN with de Blasio and he like [ __ ]
tore em apart it was actually the most
iconic thing ever like he was just
pointing out how de Blasio is like so
critical of Trump and it's like but you
literally did the same thing that you're
criticizing him it's like you said that
this wasn't gonna be a big deal and he
and they had the clips of him like
literally saying two weeks ago like just
return to normal life like I just can't
and I really have been thinking over the
weekend like Cuomo was talking about
this on my zoom on Saturday night Cuomo
like we were talking about Chris vs.
Andrew we had the same conversation and
everyone that I was talking to you said
Chris because I
it's just the obvious answer because
they're shallow but but it's really got
me thinking how everyone's talking about
Cuomo is gonna run for president yeah
and it is my understanding that he's
single maybe now he's not with Sandra
Lee anymore that was his most recent
relationship yeah so but I feel like if
he were to run for president like we'd
be seeing Sandra Lee again get what I'm
saying is Larry Slade Ely yeah we live
in like a very um like the presidency is
like a really archaic thing like you
need to have a first lady like it's very
old-school traditional and Cuomo is
gonna need a first lady and it's like
what about right we're right like who's
it gonna be it's like an episode of The
Bachelor yeah I was gonna say he should
go on The Bachelor because he would run
in four years so he has time to like
find love lasting love yeah and give us
like a snatchler first lady and who like
he's eligible because he's very handsome
he's like part of you know this famous
family and he's also the governor and
people love him right now like I just
feel like it's going down in Cuomo's DMZ
now but he's literally too busy saving
the world no totally but in Bethany
they're starting to work together that's
a match made in heaven
it's that oh my god yeah that's made in
heaven
oh my god Cuomo and Bethany I just meant
like be strong is not working I think I
met I know what you meant
I just unintentionally made a [ __ ] off
totally things are getting so crazy in
New York right now the USS comfort just
pulled up in these rivers and they're
building field hospitals in Central Park
and the Javits Center
yeah the Javits Center has been popping
off for a while now and that's like so
Javits see of them yeah I know the
Javits Center is such like an
interesting place no it's where New
Yorkers like go to Colorado yeah and so
it like was a natural bid to the job I
have been to the Javits Center
unfortunately for comic-con one year and
I was wearing shoes that were so heavy
and I couldn't get a cab on my way out
and I had to walk like literally from
14th Avenue all the way to the east side
to get a cab hi women okay it feels like
14th Avenue I had to walk with my heavy
heavy water clodhopping shoes and it was
a night I'll never forget I went to the
Javits Center once for drag Con RuPaul's
Drag Con I was on a panel with Damien
from Mean Girls and it was kind of
fabulous I'm not gonna lie but the
Javits Center
unfortunately it's nothing I'm the sort
so it being a hospital I just think it's
for the best
you know ya know I think so too in like
Central Park and USS comfort it's really
crazy how resourceful we're getting yeah
but it's it's we were watching barbara
corcoran stories because she has a view
of the park and it's really like [ __ ]
apocalyptic to watch Central Park be
turned into a field hospital yeah and
then with Barbara Corcoran's Instagram
stories I'm just now starting to feel
like the divide between the rich and the
poor has never been you know bigger her
just on her Instagram story like we get
it barber you have a park view like she
was just being so obnoxious like I
couldn't see the park if I tried you
know I understand that but I'm also
grateful to those with a park view who
are showing nice field hospitals being
set up because that's that's very very
true you know there's also I don't know
if it's a story but there's like a lot
of chatter about New Yorkers who are
fleeing to the Hamptons have you seen
all this drums I've seen a bit of drums
I've seen okay I've seen two drums I saw
the New York Post article saying that we
should burn the bridges so that they can
stop coming and then I've also seen like
backlash against just we were what in
Arielle tarnis yeah Hampton and I think
that the two are different yeah well the
thing is like the problem I didn't
understand when people were getting all
angry about people going to the Hamptons
but it's twofold like New York City is
really like a hotbed so if you're coming
and going driving back and forth like
you're just bringing germs both ways
like what are you doing and this remote
location that only has one hospital
that's my other thing not the same
resources this New York City and a
supermarket that doesn't get fully
stocked in the winter because the
population is a yes it is in the summer
but yeah well the summer people are
coming in the winter and taking all the
food yeah and it's any right yeah I
agree
did you watch on Orthodox no you what is
that okay so it's a limited series on
Netflix it's four episodes and it's
based off of a book about like a Hasidic
very very religious like ice waiting to
be her ad I don't know what it's even
considered her any woman who like leaves
the faith and goes to Berlin to like
start a new life she just like was
knocked down for the Orthodox Jewry and
goes to Berlin yeah I didn't really
understand why she went to like you know
the Holocaust vibe however century has
connections in Berlin it was like the
only place she could go I don't want to
spoil it for you it was actually really
good me in bed where who's in it nobody
literally nobody shooting on Netflix
it's an effortless original and me and
Ben were dying like there was just
honestly I really getting like and I'm
sure most subcultures feel this way like
I don't really like when there
a show highlighting like a specific part
of Judaism like maybe in a negative way
like it is really religious and I just I
don't I don't know I just don't like
people talking about my people and I'm
sure people feel the same way like ya
know you get nervous yeah it's like what
are you gonna to like of course like I
don't subscribe to that level of Judaism
but I respect people who do but there's
definitely you know there's things that
you know I don't necessarily agree with
in the in that sect of Judaism but but
it's like when they do a show like that
they only focus on those things yeah but
what why I would recommend it is I
actually think they did a great job of
like understanding the culture and the
whole show was in Yiddish I couldn't
believe it like really impressive and
they totally got like that Williamsburg
like Jewish vibe and actually I didn't
upset me really at all I thought it was
good but I keep going man Yankee which
is something you would only understand
if you watch me SD it's so many the
names were just like so Jewish speaking
of then this weekend you filmed a
premium patreon video fifth and final
episode for the month that I think is
gonna break the Internet yes a little
teaser about about the contents so Ben
is honestly like a really fabulous chef
like I couldn't even quarantine with
someone better like he makes such good
food and even on you know we're working
with limited resources with our hot
plate and our quarantined items so Ben
made a cooking video for us which have
been really popular on our patreon
recently but he there's a little twist
you know Ben kind of leads to stab a
life that a lot of people don't know
about obviously he's been his boy with
no job he's my husband he's fabulous but
he also is like a drag queen and does
you did you nya Doubtfire impersonations
and so he did the entire cooking
tutorial in his utage ania ego and it's
literally so funny I don't think
anything Ben does is funny like I'm
always like that's not funny but I was
in the kitchen literally dying like you
didn't hear me in the back you could see
you in the mirror I know you would
literally hear me in the background it's
Derek Lee laughing like when he talks
about her growing up in the patches of
Sussex it's so funny and it's being
edited today and I'll be up either today
or tomorrow so if you go to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast I
think you guys are really gonna enjoy it
it was a [ __ ] hysterical
yeah the content this month has been so
great head over to patreon.com/scishow
morning toast me of Olivia's cooking
video we have my home
we have a podcast episode and then next
month we'll probably do like five video
episodes because that's what everyone
wants in these foreign time and we have
so many pot like we're doing the podcast
here and I just feel like we need to
we're maxed out on podcasting right now
yeah and people are really looking for
the video content so we're like becoming
like vloggers oh yeah the loggers to the
core yeah um okay well there's still
like so much to discuss I feel like this
was the longest weekend ever but I guess
we could get right into it I'm sure
should we could we I think we can and we
shun you think I do it for some reason I
feel like there was something on the tip
of my tongue oh yeah there was tell you
that I made chili I did Martha Stewart's
vegetarian chili on Friday night and it
was so good we've been eating chili for
breakfast lunch and dinner there's so
many Martha Stewart honestly you guys
like I love chili too my favorite food
and I never get to eat it because it
always says mean it yeah um and so I
made a vegetarian bean chili and it was
rushed from scratch like with tomato
paste and that's what I got like all the
canned goods yeah and it was so good it
was such a treat and Zak really liked it
we've been eating it like every day
because we have the leftovers and I just
am really proud of myself I feel like
honestly I don't know if I was ever
gonna learn how to cook yeah in my life
um but without this quarantine like how
are my kids gonna eat I don't know I've
equipment now my kids are gonna be
eating chili I have a question for you
in your chili did you have red beans for
dinner I had pinto beans and black beans
that is an amazing movie for toast movie
of the day head over heels totally how
am I gonna have red beans for dinner
head over heels starring Freddie Prinze
jr. yeah and some girl who like never
got famous again no but she was fabulous
and she like pretends to be modeling
like lives with all these models in this
model it's so good oh my god wait let me
check if it's on that play you know who
liked that movie just gives me Bob's up
and I wonder if she's seen it no Emily
did not oh oh I feel like she would live
in that model apartment and be so nice
to Amanda you know by the way that's
true do you know that movie just reminds
me of Olivia I don't know why maybe she
like showed it to us well we used to
just like watch everything in her room
that's true
her room was like the hot spot it was
pink that movie always reminds me of my
friend Lisa because she used to have a
job like similar to how a man who worked
in the basement and like read a book
see I'm painting so it's like my friend
Lisa did that they don't have it on
Netflix but I'm sure they have it on
prime is do you think it'd be crazy if
we did one know they have it somewhere
experiment I watched it recently you did
yeah if I say you search it on your
Apple TV I think one streaming service
like does have it so we're doing such a
good movie we're doing it it's worth the
rental fees yeah it's it's honestly like
a better female like Zoolander almost no
actually like not at all but it just
gives me that vibe with like the model
apartment it's oh wait also I remember
the movie that we said we wanted to do
what music and lyrics which they are so
fabulous hey let's do it tomorrow okay
we'll do head over heels yeah so
everyone understands am I gonna have red
beans foot in um and the tomorrow we'll
do music and lyrics I love music and
lyrics yeah it's really good I actually
did see it recently and it holds up its
I mean that's what I thought two years
ago who knows now way back into love bum
bum ba da da da dum bum I can present
that movie is literally perfect for
quarantine because they don't leave
their apartment the whole movie they're
just like writing the song that's so
true so you won't get too jealous except
that they have a piano
we Millie I should whip out my piano
next maybe I'm learning all these new
skills too bad I can't get a car I would
learn how to drive right now I've been
practicing my guitar and it's really
frustrating honestly my fingers have
really been hurting me I have to cut my
nails like you know guitar players have
to do you love ten should be really
short it's just like a good tarp like
insider thing I'm not sure if you didn't
know that actually did and I've been
practicing my guitar it's not really
every instrument requires you to have
short nails otherwise you're just gonna
get like cut up well that's the other
thing when it comes to Orthodox like the
life that she creates her self in Berlin
like she joins us in ffunny like it's so
weird wait kind of she just say well
it's like are you gonna watch it she's
very like the black of the all-black
outfit and she's like this is a normal
athlete she's like not for the Cleveland
wait are you gonna watch on Orthodox
might I might don't okay there's like
such a funny twist because you're like
giving it good reviews it's not like
hunters no it's teracle like it's so
funny we like kind of breeze through our
recaps like we were supposed to do that
at the end of the show and it's I'm than
a movie but should we just um no no
we're gonna just go in order about
things we're gonna go into the order so
she I mean I don't watch or anything but
I don't I don't really know I'm gonna go
ahead and say that it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true jacks but business is
booming today so I'm just gonna be
grateful because you know it wasn't
moving on Friday have you ever been on a
date where someone where you just had
nothing in common with the person a lot
of people don't know this but OkCupid
has really changed the dating game by
asking you tons of questions about
yourself and what type of person you're
looking for the more questions you
answer the better they are at finding
you matches you have something in common
with some of our favorite questions from
the OkCupid dating app are you a morning
person your cord cutter you share your
streaming platform passwords with other
people so it gets to know you a little
bit better and therefore they can find
someone who's really compatible with you
not just someone with a random photo
OkCupid Works is the most mentioned
dating app in the New York Times
you can stop the mindless time on dating
apps and go to the app where you choose
what matters OkCupid is free so we don't
have a link or a code it's just download
OkCupid today go on a great date this
week and then tell us about the great
person you meet will come to the wedding
okay pupate pays us to say that but well
they're not paying us to say yes I'll
come to the wedding if you meet someone
and otq but because I told you so but I
will also get ordained officially online
and I will officiate and I will perform
a stripped-down acoustic version of my
song toast by Claudia Ashish rice so
head over and download OkCupid love it
well that's a perfect sponsor for our
first story because Ben Higgins is
engaged she was girlfriend now fiance
Jessica Clark very cute on Friday the
former bachelor star got engaged to a
longtime girlfriend Jessica Jessica
Clark she wrote I don't remember
everything you said but I know that I
said yes I woke up in a dream today and
I get to live this dream every day from
now on
eeep she shared on Saturday along with
shots of the scenic proposal so cute
they're such a cute couple
yeah they both seem I mean I don't know
her at all but they seemed both so nice
and so suited for each other yeah and
I'm just I
a happily ever after this is one of
those things that like I keep forgetting
that people are like moving forward in
their lives during warranty like this is
the first engagement I've heard about in
quarantine so I'm really really happy
for them I just feel like hearts are
breaking everywhere do you know what I
mean like he's really not my personal
vibe but like bachelor nation like they
cream their pants over Ben Higgins like
they yes like people died for him like
and brother I think he's really cute and
he's always been like so nice but be
like people don't die for him I feel
like they everyone considers him and I
don't but people like think he's just
like boring and plain no like the vibe
that I get whenever I see people talk
about him it's like oh my god like the
most eligible bachelor it's off the
market like oh yeah well he is the most
was the most eligible bachelor yeah he's
like no he is I personally think he's
everything of the sort like he's oh
she's so cute he's so philanthropic like
memory we're trying to run for mayor or
something yeah that was strange but
maybe he'll pick back up you never know
he works really hard yes I be he chose
like just a normal girl who seems like
just she's like she has her life
together he IV sees a man of taste I'm
so here for it you know it's very sweet
I just feel like a lot of hearts are
broken yeah I think mine's a little
broken no I'm totally broken just cause
like a small like 1% of me
Lorien holds out hope yeah I was
actually just gonna say born and then
happily ever after part of me really
believes that like he's still in love
with Lauren and a big part of me also
really believes he's still in love at
Jojo like he was like really torn I just
feel like he's someone who loves and
like doesn't let go like loves hard he
loves hard and he means it so yes a part
of him is still in love with those
people because he loved them that much I
came do you remember the reality show
where his headboard was made out of a
garage that was so funny and Lauren was
like we have to get rid of it yeah we
need to watch it show again by the way
that like little life they lived
temporarily in Denver Denver was so
interesting they lived in this like tiny
house like I wonder what that life was
like you know yeah I think it was hard I
think it was unpleasant if I had to
guess yes I think it was probably one of
the reasons why it didn't work out it's
just so easy today we're both living in
LA together and they have big things and
friends it would have been better it's
just a bit it all worked out the way
it's supposed to because Lauren and you
get leaner everything of the sort Lauren
Lane I am of so obsessed with her I
can't and a chance
me too that's what I was going to say
it's just so interesting how like what
has it been only like three years but
like the world is so do
you know looking at Warren it's like
married Ben Higgins is engaged like
where Jojo and Jordan so now they're
saying that their wedding is postponed
because of coronavirus but we're not I
forgot that they weren't even married
yet they've been engaged for three years
now
um so I'm not gonna blame Kron drivers
for the delay yeah no they also just
think or at the time like they were just
like young and I think in no rush
yeah no I don't sometimes I think but I
think they're so legit yeah the fact
that they haven't gotten married yet
doesn't say that they're not sometimes
when people take a long time to get
married it's like hmm what's going on
like it definitely even with like
Kaitlyn and Shawn I like was their
number one fan but for how serious they
were they were like living together and
they weren't even talking about the
wedding I was like oh something must be
off and something was off yeah but with
Jo Jo and Jordan I don't feel like it's
indicative of something being off
they're super young and and busy I just
think they're happy to like yeah yeah I
I'm not worried I'll let you know if I
do get worried though I'll get you all
in the loop yeah same okay next story is
a new couple alert that just like isn't
sitting right with me oh and I'm it
should be Oh actually it shouldn't be it
should not be and also it just like it's
gonna lead into a bunch of drama that
went down this weekend that I actually
watched the 22-minute video of Daisy
Keach taking down the hype house oh yeah
Brody Jenner appears to be quarantining
with 20 or okay I'm sorry Brody Jenner
36 appears to be quarantine with 20-year
old tic-tock star Daisy Keach after
splitting from Kaitlyn Carter and then
Josie Canseco
okay Daisy key I understand that she's
20 but she looks 55 years old like what
to me she looks 15 oh my god
the way the way that she like dresses
and acts and her tick-tocks and her ass
and like her low-rise jeans like she
literally looks like she's 75 years old
talking about oh my god it looks like an
18 like no no she looks yes her face
looks Joey but her vibe is like 97 are
you kidding me out of sight out of my 97
I mean like 35 like so old like she
doesn't the way that she looks in the
way that she acts and dresses do not
match up for me like she looks like a
child but she's so mature like her
tactics are so sexual like
right new yeah sexual in the way that
like a child's are sexual honestly 35
year olds don't behave that way on
tik-tok no it's just like she she could
see like 35 year old pornstar vibe
Wow really overly sexy oh no to me she
gives me like Instagram model hot five
also looks just like Lilly Reinhart I
totally agree it's like a craze and I
just want to say like I really like her
and first of all I mean I feel like the
whole world feels this way like we just
like Brody Jenner I feel like he's just
like all of our like big brother and
little brother it has a lot to do with
like us all growing up on the hills and
just like a really like him being our
dream guy yeah Plus Keeping Up with the
Kardashians like just he really is like
a cornerstone of pop culture he's a
staple in Hollywood for sure he is but
like this is where I draw the line I
have to agree this is really um
disgusting this is too young I agree and
yeah I agree
like will will give Scott and Sophia
Pass and even that it's just a little
hard to swallow what Scott and Sophia's
age difference okay actually I feel like
it might be but Sophia Richie's like 21
okay Scott is 36 the exact same age as
Brody Jenner and Sophia where she is 21
so it's just one year difference yeah
but they have you have two years under
their belt of relationship and if in two
years Brody and Daisy are going strong
yeah and quarantining together maybe I
would allow it also to me like Sophia
Richie's 21 is so much more than Daisy
teaches twenty like so favorite she grew
up in Hollywood like you grow up super
fast like I it's still not right but to
me like I don't get the father-son but
of the father-daughter vibe that I do
with Brody and Daisy also like both of
their names end in Y and I just feel
like that's hard like pretty Daisy
that's like a really cute couple name
but I'm sorry Dee I know that I really
try me age line but like I just I can't
I can in this in this situation plus
their grocery shopping together are they
quarantine any other how serious is this
relationship where did she make that
video that she just posted yeah which
was um like took the world by storm took
the world by storm I watched it last
night and it's really crazy and like so
Charlie's man is a scammer yeah but like
you know what I don't really know who to
believe you know I believe desi 100% by
the way just go back really quickly back
to this whole Daisy Brody thing um where
her parents you know yeah I don't know
I mean tragic I don't know how Hollywood
take it back
young girl oh yeah but that's just
Hollywood at least she's making her own
choices and dating whoever she wants and
yeah Mike also like I saw her in a video
like with Logan Paul and I was like I
don't know she's falling into like a
rough crowd but like this is rougher no
this is like nothing that was nothing
like he's gay is he gonna be on the
hills I would love that you know what I
wouldn't dislike that so why not but
like how did these two meet also like oh
I think part of the reason why why we
feel like she might be so young like her
20 is nothing to 21 year old Sophie it's
because she's on tic-tock tic-tock is
like a child nothing
and she's like associated with Charlie
who is 15 and Addison who was younger
than 20 yeah 17 I think so yeah I she
can't even drink legally yeah no wait oh
yeah no she can't oh my god you know how
these clubs with him
yeah with Frankie I don't know maybe
that's why they're suited for quarantine
yeah maybe it's just like a quarantine
fling like a spring fling yeah or maybe
she uses Lily reinhardt's ID maybe I
mean she should definitely ask because
it's it's a perfect match yeah anyways
let's talk about the video because he's
taking down the high pass so I can like
barely watched I watched like a 30
second fun and so that's perfect because
you know all the backstory and all I
know is the video okay so what I know
about the hype house is this guy Thomas
who is nothing of the sort
I looked him up at I agree how is this
the mastermind questions are it's been
like just understood in the tic-tock
community that hype house came together
with this guy Thomas like he is the
brains of the operation he you know lil
honey really just Thomas I didn't even
never hear little honey being the brains
of the operation it was my understanding
that Thomas like has worked in YouTube
marketing before he's like done houses
with other youtubers and when it came to
tick tock like he had this idea it was
all him and he got all the people
together like that is the understanding
and they all got really big from it and
relationships started and people have
come and go and I heard that jay-z left
and Charlie was like back and forth and
none of them really live in the house
but as far as I knew just as like a big
fan of chick talk and a big fan of the
hip hop hype outs is that Thomas was the
mastermind
okay now according to the video what is
now according to the video it was Daisy
Thomas chase who is lil hoodie and then
some people something with a K that was
that
then posted on instagram Corvo or
something no I don't know she's dating
some guy I literally okay so they needed
money to put down for this house that
they found on Zillow so that they could
have a house of creators and it was
everyone's idea Daisy
and chase gave $18,000 Oh Tommy each
each Thomas gave $5,000 that's what he
had and in that couple kaurav no and her
boyfriend gave $5,000 so Daisy and chase
are the big owners of house Daisy's name
is on the lease
then everyone deceive $18,000 she was
like influencing before what about will
honey
I have no idea I have no idea she didn't
explain like the financials okay for
those listening to the podcast I'm sorry
Theo snoring but I'm not sorry beautiful
so sorry not sorry it's a beautiful
sound
okay so then when they got into the
house of hype Thomas made all the
socials and an email and he didn't share
the passwords with anyone so anything
that was posted to the Instagram or the
tic-tock page like only he could post of
the ad hype house of the ad hype house
any like sponsorships went through the
email that only he managed and he told
them that the hype house has made $0
they didn't know when they were working
with product if they were just being
like right you know promoting for just
product or being paid he was like saying
that no one was getting paid for and
associated in like all these interviews
impress like chase and Thomas were
taking credit for it being their idea
when like jay-z was very much a
co-founder and put down more money then
Thomas and she just felt like she was
being pushed out of everything
everything was like really [ __ ] shady
and Thomas is like manipulative and
every time desi would come to and be
like hey like this ain't right like you
need to like give me credit you'd be
like yeah yeah and then he'd just go and
do it again so he doesn't tell her what
she wanted to hear who was paying the
rent um I don't know maybe all the kids
like I was sleeping there I don't know
if they had to pay rent like they put
down 46,000 dollars
Oh like a mortgage I don't think they
bought the house cuz they do have a
landlord um but maybe they like paid six
months cuz what it wouldn't be one month
is 46,000 dollars maybe it was like a
big mansion in Beverly Hills I don't
know they she didn't specify
okay I would love to know more about the
logistics but that's so sad that they're
pushing her out but she's doing just
fine like yeah and then she was like
talking about how she wished she had
like a man
sure at the time like who would like
have you know protected her and speared
her in the right direction
because Thomas like did have that and
then Daisy when in trademark type house
which was smart huh but now they're
selling hype house merch yeah and who is
Gary from that because she trademarked
it yeah so they're just like all these
like teenagers who were arguing about
how to be business people right because
their to nature obviously was very well
maybe she'll like they were just like
calling themselves business people good
I love business is just like all this
drama but justice her Daisy because
she's so cute she's so cute she's on the
high pass videos it's just like those
three guys I think quarantine like
Addison went home the de Mille o--'s
went home quarantine is just like
destroy promise and the Lopez brothers
and Taylor holder and Bryce hall and
like literally all my least favorite
people Andre as ondrea's Lopez I think
that's his name like one of the twins
like hazel longer hair but he actually
recently just cut it like I watch his
video isn't like I actually want to die
like I just want to like jump out the
window
know like these boys just like making
videos of themselves like it's going
downhill so fast yeah any cute with fun
because the girls added this element of
like young hot caught people living in a
house and the girls are cool in the
fashion are they all dating who knew
right but now it's just like a bunch of
dudes like in a house literally in a hot
tub at night and it's just like kind of
lame being losers and now we know that
they were like scamming girls for their
money oh and Daisy said that at one
point there was a really popular creator
she wouldn't say who who they wanted in
the house and Thomas said to her um can
you let go like being like the friend
her and be really nice to her so that
she'll feel like she wants to join cuz
she has friends here and so she was like
if he's telling me to do that to someone
like he probably telling someone to do
that to me yeah but you want to say what
was that he definitely gave me like a
D'Amelio atisan vibe yeah but cuz did
the girl eventually make it in the house
I think so I she didn't say she could
she she didn't want to like throw anyone
else under the bus as a point that was
not the point
oh my god I hope she gets a lot of
subscribers worth noting that like
Addison and Charlie and Dixie like still
follow her yeah and they're being
supportive so I feel like it's really
like the girls are gonna take down the
guys and the other four then it's like
it gets complicated with Charlie and
little honey I don't think that it does
I think that lil Hadi is absolutely
nothing of the sort like Charlie had her
fun
but I think it's over also then I was
talking to snitch about it cuz I was
like I need more backstory now that I'm
invested and she said that Bryce who was
part of sway house Oh at understand sway
house but he was a part of hi pals okay
well Bryce is now a part of sway house
and he just released a dish track
Oh about a little hottie by the way but
about little honey in like Thomas and
pipe house and in the diss track he says
that lil honey was texting one of the
girls in sway house and so then little
Hut he was cheating on charlie and we
don't stand for that like honestly this
is this is the byproduct of a generation
of kids who's like role models were Jake
and Logan Paul like coming out with dis
tracks and that's just like that is our
culture now and that's the vibe like
these kids who just like grab their
dicks and dance on camera and like stick
their tongues out and like dead that's
that's it and I'm honestly I've never
been so glad to be old honestly this is
what happens when you get famous in 0.5
seconds and then you like pop up and
you're on Ellen and this in there and
that you're doing with your friends who
aren't your friends and do these people
have my back and we live in LA and we
live in this house and who are my family
I mean I'm so like happy for Charlie
that she has her sister in this and her
parents like the kids who have their
parents are much better off like Sheree
is like they all have parents who like
probably look out for hit them but like
to have your sister like in the group
you know who you can trust
yeah there was just like a six-month
period maybe less where the hype house
was everything of the sort like Dixie
Daisy Charlie added a bond like it was
three month money and so it was just
like it's so funny how their mighty have
fallen nobody really lives there anymore
and to be honest I've always felt that
little hottie was absolutely nothing of
the sort
obviously now hearing the diss track and
what it entails I'm now certain that
he's nothing of the sort but Charlie to
me is just like the biggest star in the
world like I saw her on a commercial
yesterday for like the Kids Choice
Awards like she's the biggest star and
not only should she not even be dating a
tank talker she shouldn't be dating no
offense an ugly one so also little honey
was texting Nessa
do you know her I don't know her I know
Nessa from girl code who hosts the taxi
TV
that's my generation's Nessa so I'm not
familiar with the new ones but that's
that's just actually love that other
Nessa for me too I think she's fabulous
I think she's fabulous as well so that's
what the kids are up to you guys it's
really crazy but it's weird because
that's what the kids are up to and Brody
Jenner right and now Brody Jenner is
involved and
I just don't understand yeah that's
where things are getting like a little
dicey and confusing for me
yeah but I'm glad that at least AC like
has someone right now that she can just
like be cool with yeah while she's
taking down these losers yeah and I
might be spotted in the Daily Mail kids
are so mad I hope that they're like all
being nice to her like you know like on
YouTube I think that I think people are
but I I do think people are but I also
didn't read any of it I just like made
my own opinions
ya know same and I'm sure we're like
half wrong about someone like this way
House high pass information but I don't
care I got it directly from the snitch
which means true a reliable source okay
next up Lady Gaga's dad is being slammed
for asking for donations to pay
restaurant staff I did hear about this
times are tough for many due to the
spread of coronavirus including the
father of pop superstar Lady gaga
an owner of several New York eateries
the restaurateur recently created the
GoFundMe account asking the public to
donate 50 thousand dollars to cover his
staffs wages at Upper West Side spot
Joann trattoria and was immediately met
with criticism from masses restaurants
across the world have in order to close
their doors in an effort to encourage
self isolation and curb the spread of
Kovan 19 so I'm assuming the backlash is
because jobs your daughters a
multimillionaire
has an album named Joanne Wright the
singer earned thirty nine point five
million dollars in 2019 according to
Forbes yes oh yeah
I feel very two ways about this like to
start a GoFundMe when like your
daughter's the biggest pop star in the
world like it's just a little out of
touch but at the same time like just
because your daughter's a millionaire
doesn't mean you are but I would hope
that she's the type of millionaire who
takes care of her parents but you never
know no but I do I she's very close with
her family I just wish he would have
been here as a parent you don't want to
go to your child and be like can I get
fifty grand
I know but these are like uncertain
times I feel like if there ever was a
moment to ask your multi-millionaire
daughter for 50 grand like it would be
during the quarantine and it's not like
he needs it for himself like it's for
the betterment of just like regular
people and I feel like she would
actually be more than happy to help
totally so this just seems strange yeah
it is but I like hate they're like a
poor old man's getting backlash like
leave him know he's not a celebrity I
agree I totally agree it's like maybe
don't like it just don't don't it was
like we can disagree on something
without there being backlash that is
Chrissy Teigen 'he's like claim to fame
and I totally agree like and
there's a major cancellation like she's
always speeding like you can dislike
someone and like stop supporting them
without making an official statement you
can also just disagree with one thing
that someone does and then just move on
with the rest of your day and still know
and also still like them but just like
disagree with it with one thing ya know
so I don't think we should be like
coming for and cancelling like an
average citizen especially like an older
man you know but at the same time I
definitely I see the weirdness that
people are referring to and I to him and
feeling like it's weird yes I do I see
it I hear it but you know like the money
that he needs to support his staff or
whatever the funds would be going to is
a glittery one chartered plane for Lady
Gaga like it's nothing less Latika got
less than they were just replaying
yesterday all day yesterday season 10 of
Real Housewives of New York on Bravo
saw your story and I just think that it
was one of the greatest seasons and I
remember we were on the toast recapping
and it was only like two years ago but
so much has happened in the world since
then like Carol's not even on the show
that I had forgotten about it but we
watching it like it still cuts deep you
know it does and I still feel the same
exact way I felt about it
back then that Bethenny was treated so
unfairly by all the women and it's just
so funny how Bethenny went on for
another season and was like friends with
Dorinda and friends with Tinsley and
Timmy like they were the worst and
Ramona to even like the way that they
all just like turned against her at like
such a dark time in her life with her
custody battle like it's genuinely so
painful to watch and I just loved
Bethenny and that now reminded that we
are going to have a season without her
and it's just gonna be nothing of the
sort
no but you know what like it was just it
never added up like the fact that she
just you know put water under the bridge
and socialized with her mon under and
they even though they like totally
stabbed her and I close with Tinsley
yeah when jhinsley was like the catalyst
for the whole thing she was but she
never did anything like wrong to
Bethenny I actually think Tinsley
handled herself really well in that
situation considering she was completely
in the middle she know she wasn't in the
middle cuz she wasn't even friends with
Bethenny like Sheen even Oh Bethenny
anything she was just like good friends
with Carole and somehow that friendship
with Carole like rubbed Bethenny the
wrong way and became like a big thing in
their life but I just met through a
union and they were all just really like
especially Ramona and Dorinda like
really just like they just wanted to be
on the majority side like I want to
thought that was
Carl said but like tensely being
careless best friend like could have
been as much with them as anyone else
but there were moments in the reunion
when Tinsley and Bethenny really saw
eye-to-eye yeah and that's actually
reminded me a lot of this current season
of Shahs of Sunset where like I think
that Bethenny and Carole like the cast
thought that the world would side with
Carole like Bethenny the big bad villain
were finally taking her down so everyone
kind of went with Carole but in the end
the audience was much more sympathetic
to Bethany situation and that's what I'm
really feeling like it's coming on in
Chaz's sunset like the cast they're
obviously all really good friends but
the cast is really thirsty and they just
want to be liked by everyone and they
want to get good ratings so I think that
they all thought that like being on
Reza's side would be the right choice
like the audience was gonna side with
Reza but I think from what I'm seeing
for the most part as most people are
really sympathetic to MJ yeah and that
now that a whole cast looks like a bunch
of [ __ ]
except for Mike he's like the only
person with a good head on his shoulders
and Theodore fat come on he's being so
[ __ ] cute right now like I
literally have you ever just wanted to
like take your dog or your daughter or
whatever your husband like whoever you
the audience at home whoever you love
like who ever wanted to take them smoosh
them up to a ball and just so wallow
them but never make a doodie ever again
so they just stay in your belly forever
like you don't digest him and [ __ ] him
out like he just sits in your belly
that's like in little fires everywhere
seeds and all sigh seeds and all seeds
and all you want to eat the whole Apple
season all but you just have to get used
to only his smell it reminded me of
Twilight you know you just want to eat
human beings but you just have to get
used to only the smell yeah and just
kind of suck enough to get the poison
out but not enough to train their blood
totally okay next story speaking of
cuties Drake shares first pictures of
Sun Adonis while self isolating quoting
love and miss my beautiful family
Drake is offering fans a rare glimpse
into his personal life on Monday the in
my feelings rapper posted a handful of
photos of his two-year-old son Adonis to
Instagram with a heartfelt message about
being apart from his family during the
corona virus pandemic it's the first
time Drake has ever revealed photos of
his son whom he shares with artist and
former adult film star Sophie Bruce so
he's previously posted glimpses into his
life as a dad sharing shots of his son's
artwork father's days gifts and birthday
party decorations but never any photos
of Adonis so this bebut is really
[ __ ] cute yeah I was a story I always
think it's crazy when celebrities can
Cecily hide the like physical appearance
of the child or their boyfriend like no
one really knows what it tells kids look
kid looks like they just like barely
another kid's name it's like Anthony or
something I just find it really
impressive and I think that's really
cool and actually really smart I can't
imagine how scary it is to like have
birth give birth to a child and then
like everyone knows about it it just
would freak me out yeah this kid is so
cute like literally his blond hair blue
eyes like so cute so perfect I didn't
even know not that I'm like a big Drake
fan like that I wouldn't know this but I
didn't know he had like a kid no it was
a it was so as weird because someone
basically no one knew that he had a kid
and then like one of the rappers
released a diss track like kind of
outing the fact that he had a child with
someone and then so the world just like
new and one instant but then like people
start talking about it because they like
we're giving him his privacy oh that's
nice yeah respect privacy yeah when it
comes to actually that's not true but
I'm glad that people did yeah or at
least like I feel like I have Drake is
Jewish yes a little bit he's like what
does he his momma's Chewie he's half
Jewish yeah which half hey babies a
quarter Jewish probably his mom so his
baby's a quarter joke what's his real
name Drake Aubrey Graham a Jewish last
name no that's why I think get a mom
mm-hmm cute super cute okay you know the
same way with Ben Higgins I think like
hearts are breaking everywhere when it
comes to this like Drake is I don't even
know if he's wiped up but like he has a
family out and about he's a man about
town I feel like every city he goes to
he's just like meeting new people yeah
putting himself out there going on
OkCupid yeah I feel like he's one of
those that those types of people who
just like loves making new friends yeah
totally
I love that for him as well I'm ready
for a fifth and final story I am but if
I could just quickly give an important
announcement because I think a lot of
people you know things were so crazy
right now but they may forget that we
still gotta pay our taxes this year even
though it feels like a weird year that's
why I think it's important to let you
guys know that today's episode is
brought to you by turbo tax people do
amazing things every day so it makes no
sense that they shouldn't feel confident
about doing their taxes Turbo Tax
believes that with the right tools and
encouragement people can do anything yes
even taxes and with turbo tax live you
have access to CPAs and EAS on demand
who are able to answer your questions or
to give advice on how to file even on
nights and weekends so you can do your
taxes with ease and confidence and never
stuck or alone during the tax process
you can also rest assured that you'll
get your best possible outcome which
means you can file taxes quickly and
easily and get back to all the amazing
things that you do every day
TurboTax all people are tax people
thanks TurboTax love it love tax season
okay next up a blast from the past some
drive-in movie theaters are making a
comeback amid coronavirus I love it I
love this some drive-ins throughout the
US are benefiting from the coronavirus
as Americans look for activities that
meet social distancing requirements and
movie theater chains like AMC are closed
but it's only between 5% and 10% of all
drive-ins so drive-ins have been forced
to shut down but now some people are
able to open up and people can do
drive-in movie theaters it's a great way
to social distance so are you saying
that there are pre-existing drive-in
movie theaters right now yes
so we're open before the quarantine yes
so I don't know about that I believe so
so I mean this is great but I feel like
where we live in New York and first of
all since we're like the epicenter of
American coronavirus like they're not
playing around they're not giving us any
[ __ ] drive-ins and I don't think that
there are drive-ins in Manhattan so I
feel like the story it doesn't apply to
me but I'm happy for the people that it
does yeah I'm happy for the people that
it does like a lot of you know social
distancing perks don't apply to us like
a fireplace or a pool yeah but I'm happy
for the people that they do I would just
love to have a fireplace or a pool if
you could choose one I think a pool I
think a fireplace well depends if you
just stare at that fire forever if I get
a pool and then it's cold out like
what's the point you know yeah be a
teepee geez quarantined at his like um
lake house and he was facetiming with me
and he was sitting by this fabulous
fireplace and was off and I'm like
excuse me why is your fireplace off do
you know how lucky you are my fireplace
would never be off and then you could
also like make s'mores maybe I could
make my chili over for the fireplace
oh wow that's so Game of Thrones just go
to town like I swear to God like in a
few weeks you're gonna see me starting a
little fire in my apartment little fires
everywhere could buy one of the they
make I know what they make what I mean
they make those like steak Amish why are
they Amish I don't know I don't know
fireplaces that are for sad people like
me yeah but I'm not that sad yet but I
don't know like talk to me in one day
because right things change a day in
quarantine is like a week in the real
world things change so much like I could
be spewing things right now that I
genuinely believe and then tomorrow like
I'm a wholeheartedly disagree with them
because so much will happen between now
and tomorrow show it's just like so
crazy how I sat here so factually saying
I would never work out in my apartment
and not only do I work out in my
apartment now but I got like a
state-of-the-art bike and I'm there
every day just bumping and jumping on
Friday I did a pink ride oh you mean pee
' the exclamation n K ride
' guys if you're a pellet toaster which
there of course there is a pellet
toaster group it was the best ride ever
like the greatest showmen ride was also
the best ride ever but this one was
actually maybe even better it was crazy
and then I did another ride with Cody
who's an instructor of toasters love and
the opening song was um Celine Dion
which one sorry that's the way it is Wow
and I just when I wanted it the most
there was no easy way out that's the
thing though when you when you genuinely
do wanted the most
there is never never an easy way out no
but you know what that's that that's the
way I'm just so happy that like the
quarantine happened right after the
Celine Dion concert like we got to see
her I know but I was there like jazz
hands don't touch me
there's no easy way am i on Saturday
night when I started clawing Ben was
doing his Legos and I was like getting
wasted in the living room and I started
singing like I literally gave a full
concert performance and I have to say
like my voice is getting so good like I
sang home from Country Strong which you
know I sing at your wedding terribly and
it was a disgrace and I'm sorry but I'm
getting better and I was just like
giving this performance in the living
room and I was thinking like Ben didn't
even like look up from his [ __ ] Legos
to see the star in his living room and
it's like I just wish that I was
quarantined with someone so talented you
know yeah oh yeah I guess like if you
could be quiet if you could add one more
person to your quarantine and they would
have their own rooms so like you don't
have to worry about spec Eman who would
you add I
at someone who's like talented I would
add someone who's a really fun and like
down to throw down and like funny and I
don't get annoyed with so I think I feel
like anyone who's like fun and town to
throw down and funny like gets annoying
right I know thank you that's me like
I'm getting annoying I don't know that's
something to think about you know but I
don't have a second bedroom so it's
actually not anything to think about cuz
it's never gonna happen oh no but it's
just like it was a hypothetical you know
like I do lobby would come with an a
next room yeah yeah so before we had Top
Chef or something before we kept little
fires everywhere did you watch anything
else this weekend that you want to talk
about so on Friday what did i do on
Friday me I don't I don't even on
Saturday I think I watched the bold type
oh and I read a book called when we were
mermaids that was really good I don't
know if it's a good book or a bad book
but I enjoyed it there were some things
that we're like a little like fantasy
like every you know stupid but I really
liked it it's free on Kindle unlimited
and it was about it was a beautiful book
about sisters mmm and the bond of
sisterhood and it just it got me my
feelings which is where I stayed all
weekend like I'm literally if I don't if
the good day goes by and I don't cry
like that's a good day oh that's
interesting
I think I've cried every single day for
the last like 14 is never one dumb
reason another I haven't cried we're
just like seeing a video like the Lady
Antebellum I run to you video oh my god
that was fabulous but now it makes me
like I want more I on another one that's
it's just so interesting how certain
people are putting out like music
content that's like bothering me so much
and some people are like totally
reigniting my love of Lady Antebellum
you know that was a fabulous video it
was a fabulous video and it's like if
they can do that and also that video
like just may mean I know I hate to
compare like to pick country music bands
against one another
but like seeing them do that reminded me
that in a world without Rascal Flatts
like I might be okay and I don't think
we've actually spoken about how this
quarantine is going to affect the final
Rascal Flatts farewell tour because I
don't think that we can handle it like
you can only take out as much as you can
handle and I can't think about that and
that's why I think both of us are really
postponing and making any real decision
about Kim toast may 1st is when the
decision comes down yeah so honestly
like based on everything that we've been
told like in the news and stuff it's
very much up in the air I guess yeah
like it is only a gathering of 300
people like it's not Coachella
yeah but it's against the maxim we could
have everyone come in and take their
temperatures and like make sure your
you'll have an in-house infirmary
yeah like lice checks corona checks okay
let's jump into our toast assignment of
the week when assignment of the weekend
was little fires everywhere which is a
series based off of a book starring
Kerry Washington and Reese Witherspoon
it is on Hulu they're releasing an
episodic language you kind of glad the
episodes are so long and hadn't read the
book um and I wanted the cessation of
comparing did you like the book uh no
and I wanted the cessation of comparing
and I want to tell you the cessation is
not good because having read the book
then I see all this stuff in the movie
I'm like that didn't happen that didn't
happen that wasn't like that she didn't
do that because of that and they make
everything so much more nefarious yeah
so obviously because you need to fill
these whole long episodes and I'm just
like that's not the way that's the left
hand intended that's not the way yeah
and that's the thing it's not the way it
is but the show is better than the book
because Reese Witherspoon is like
Illyricum oh sorry I just want to know
if you like the web cast and I was like
a short question that was meant to just
like be like yeah and then I dive into
that never how it goes when you ask me
about a book redheads episode drops on
Thursday I know you saw they'd be like
pick up my cards how are you gonna do
anything only yes there's gonna be a
little bit of remote a little bit of
studio action we're gonna try and get it
to be the best ever but I think you guys
are all getting used to from other
podcasts not this one
yeah shitty podcast audios so redheads
we'll be right there with them
so our new the sponsor of today's
episode is new and actually came at the
perfect time because I never thought I'd
be the type of person who like needed a
water filter but in these uncertain
times you truly never know and the
clearly filtered water filter is a new
way to think about filtration their
breakthrough affinity filtration
technology reinvents the way that water
filters work by capturing and destroying
over 230 chemicals contaminants and
toxins common commonly found in tap
water most water filters only focus on
making your water taste better when
clearly filtered does that it make sure
what are healthier by removing hundreds
of toxins and also keeps the beneficial
minerals in your water
the EPA only tests and regulates 91
chemicals that are found in tap water
many other chemicals like PF phase
pesticides herbicides chromium 6 which
is Erin Brockovich vibes and many others
are unregulated and therefore you would
never know that they're in your tap
water so a good
Harrison is basically a standard carbon
water filter is bulletproof vest that
only stops paintballs which is the
clearly fit versus the clearly filtered
filter which is a vest that stops nearly
everything so first of all it's
beautiful by the way it's like so sleek
and I really like the way that it looks
in my fridge and is really easy to set
up like I just watched just like a
little man in this video and he's like
told me exactly what to do and I'm just
like that girl with like clean water
filtration system you're the dad and
sleepover yes oh my god I just never
thought that I would be that type of
girl but I'm so glad that I am mm-hmm I
really like clearly filtered all of
their filters are made in the u.s. in
Alabama to be exact so our Alabama
toasters roll tide and you if you
contact the company they really pride
themselves on customer service you have
a question or comment contact them
they're always happy to help call text
chat email social media whatever you
prefer and if you're looking to get a
clearly filter to filter which I feel
like now is the time we have an offer
for you guys you can get 20% off your
new clearly filtered system with code
toast at checkout so go to clearly
filtered com get 20% off your new
clearly filtered system with code toast
at checkout lid on drink clean water
little fires everywhere so did you binge
all four episodes yes I did and it was
it was tough because episodes are really
long and as I said they just like add
all this fluff like to make it
made-for-tv but isn't Shaker Heights
like everything of the sort oh it's
everything of the sort and that's like
the part about it that makes it such a
good show and in the book like Elena
Richardson like there are things about
her like that she said that are so
likeable but you need to use people's
names in real life because I have
absolutely no idea who is character in
the book she's like she's very strict
tonight I don't really relate to her
that much but when Reese plays her I'm
like oh my god that's me yeah no and
she's fabulous too and I feel like now
she waits that's funny that's literally
me that's Joe funny no I liked her too
and I can compare with the book because
I didn't read it but I really liked her
and I think like yeah when it comes to
relationship with Kerry Washington like
she's a little like out of touch but she
has good intentions and she's not a
[ __ ] and I really like her and I think
she's so cute and I love her house so
much like I just need that house like I
need to live there ya know in the book
like the dynamic between them is is a
little different and also like it's like
snitch says she likes reading books
because you
get to know what the characters are
thinking like why Lisa's doing the
things that she's doing right and in the
book her character like is a little bit
more nefarious but when recently was
just a fairy it's like just like like
bad intentions you know oh but not all
pure and good everyone Reese plays her
I'm like oh my god she's the sweetest
person I don't think she wants to just
be such a good mom and like such a good
friend and just be there for everyone
well then that's frustrating because I
feel like they make like and in the book
like Mia is isn't as bad as she is in
the show right because in the show
they're making it impossible to like
Carrie Washington like she's so mean she
is this chip on her shoulder and she
just thinks everyone's out to get her
when they're not like people like this
really genuinely likes her and like
wanted them to be friends and I think
like she has it was awkward when she
asked her to be her maid but she like
thought she was doing the right thing
she was just gonna have to give this
woman money but she gave her a job like
I see how that could be misconstrued as
rude but like when you see the car that
she's driving like you she just wants to
help so that must be that's annoying
that it's not the same in that regard
but I yeah it's like Mia is supposed to
be just like one kind of person and
Elena is just another kind of person I
feel like in when you're reading the
book you might relate more to me even
and eventually like you'll get her
backstory yeah and you might understand
why she is the way that she is I'm like
literally dragging her daughter all
around the country like why can't and
but well you'll understand in the show
pearl is everything is what pearl is
everything of the sort I just want pearl
to be like the most popular girl at
school
honestly I shiver and trip Moody is too
moody he's annoying and he's a loser
like pearl is his cool girl I'm like her
energy just like people are really
attracted to her she rather Tate towards
her I'm sorry like a girl like that
doesn't go with the Moody she goes with
a trip and I thought the way they like
trip like ran out of the bed like made
her feel like a [ __ ] like I that really
made me sad because I think pearls
everything of the sort and I like ship
pearl and trip and I really ship pearl
and race know same and like that's hard
that's like the dynamic that they get
really right from the book cos pearl is
just like such a great kid yeah and she
like has been through a lot and like
she's had an not traditional childhood
where she was like living in her car in
the beginning of the show and she just
still has a good attitude and the fact
that she just like had to beg her mom to
stay in this like normal town where they
have a good life and they have a great
apartment and then she have a good job
like the fact that she had to beg her
mom were like she's almost the adult in
a lot of situations like that was
frustrating yeah
is frustrating also I think that the
show like really gets the 9 these like
so spot-on like the kids first of all
the way that the kids are cast and
dressed um the casting is perfect first
of all the four kids look like siblings
yeah
maybe and Tripp really do they all
really look like high school kids
students like yes easy looks like a
freshman Tripp looks like a senior and
that's so hard in Hollywood they never
get it right it's like thirty year olds
playing high school students yeah can I
just say like I don't read the book and
I'm pretty sure last night I predicted
what I think is gonna happen just I
don't want to look at your face I'll
turn around but it's very obvious that
Reese's older daughter is pregnant or is
gonna get pregnant if she keeps [ __ ]
her boyfriend and they're like oh you're
glowing like from having sex no she's
lying cuz she's pregnant so she devil
Inc is worth mailing the baby goes to BB
and Linda who is like the saddest
character and just genuinely cannot
catch a break
gets Reese's daughters baby if I had to
guess but I don't look at you okay I'm
just gonna move on from everything that
you said let's quickly talk about the
whole baby situation because it's really
frustrating like first of all Kerry
Washington once again like putting her
ass where it doesn't belong like getting
involved in people's businesses even
like Bibi is that the woman's name like
even sheathe I didn't she's like I wish
I didn't even know where the baby was
oh yeah in the book she never says that
she wishes that she didn't know so they
really want to make Kerry Washington
like even ever unlikable cuz in the book
it's like Kerry Washington like did the
right like some people would say she did
the right thing some people wouldn't
it's very much like what side are you on
I'm sure like as the episodes go on like
it'll become you know it will depend how
you feel based on your feelings right so
how do you feel outside of all the
characters like a woman drops off her
baby this is just take it out of the
show but just in real life a woman drops
off her baby she can't handle it at a
fire station and this you know couple
who has a really hard time getting
pregnant gets the baby house maybe for
you it gives me a fabulous light here a
year of loving a baby that they thought
there was their own yeah baby a fabulous
life it's almost done with the adoption
process and then the birth mother like
decides that she can now take on the
baby and wants to be the baby's mom
again like who do you the law gives the
baby to the birth mother because the law
is the law
but like ethically the baby has to stay
with Linda
right I mean it just it's like I don't
know if I were the judge
I don't know well if you're the judge I
think you have to side with the law and
the law is this is the birth mother and
she never formally gave the baby up for
adoption but like it is a crime when
Reese like slammed her hands on the
table she was like you should be in jail
for what you did to that baby it's true
he looked a baby on the cold yeah I got
all those flashbacks of May laying and
BB like what you couldn't feed her it
was so sad yeah in the book and they
explained I mean I don't know if they'll
wind up explaining like what she
actually I think that was the
explanation when she couldn't feed her
and that she spent like her last seven
dollars on formula yeah um and then like
when she even wrapped her at the fire
station like you see mate um be be like
take off her own sweater and she's
wearing a sleeveless top like she did
everything to make sure that baby was
okay like gave her everything that she
possibly had and those circumstances led
her to Linda and whatever know the guys
name is like with a great life
yeah and but I think also she was
dealing with um postpartum depression
yes and she didn't she didn't know what
to do yeah and what what do you do I
don't know I don't it's really it's
really complex situation but then as you
we learn more you'll understand more
where people are coming from yeah I just
I just really Kerry Washington's
character is so unlikable and to be
honest I've never seen Kerry Washington
act in anything I just like like her as
a celebrity I never watched scandal but
like I'm sorry she's not a good actress
like and everyone keeps talking about
her lip and like all she does is like
move her teeth and her lip around like
to act and like I could do that too like
I'm acting but she's really and I don't
know if it's just because her character
so unlikable or Kerry Washington is just
not a good actress I don't know either
because I don't know if they made a
decision to make it her more unlikable
but I don't even know why they would do
that because it's like there should be
more of a discussion like Elena there
are some things that she'll do
eventually where it's like you're not
always gonna be on her side but they're
having it someone's like they're making
it impossible yes and so like right now
in my mind Elena has not done anything
wrong like she's been overly nice like
maybe she overstepped a little bit with
pearl or with offering her a job but at
the end of the day I think she was
coming from a good place
so that at the end of this most recent
episode for [ __ ] Kerry Washington to
be burning a picture for like dramatic
yeah dramatic like she really is such a
nice woman but I think also it's maybe
because of the way that Reese like
reese witherspoon it's Elle Woods like
we can have no choice but to stand no
but also we have no choice but to stand
because we've not been led you know the
book but I'm just saying as someone
who's only watch a show they have made
it seem like race literally is an angel
like she only is coming from a good
place
yeah and I think that that even in the
book like that's that's where we're at
halfway through the book and I totally
like in the beginning wasn't even hating
Kerry Washington because I understood
that she obviously had like a pass and
she had this chip on her shoulder and it
was like something that she just lives
with but now it's like just be nice like
chill the [ __ ] out I actually think that
when you find out is it not gonna be
enough you're gonna hate her yeah okay I
think it's good though I really like the
show I love the neighborhood like I just
love the set I love the cast like I love
it I could get a whole spin-off about
the kids like in the high school no I
love the kids
I grow everything of the sort like when
she oh my god when she just have a scary
spice and moody was like that's racist
she was like I wanted to be scary but
it's like sometimes it's just like not
that serious I just I love her and I
love the older daughter and I like Lexie
and I love like her boyfriends like
[ __ ] in the limo like I just I love
the high school I think they add stuff
that just kind of bothers me like first
of all in the book Lexie didn't steal
her story pearl helps her write her
essay like just because pearls a good
writer
yeah like Lexie I she's obviously like
reefs 2.0 and that's the whole vibe and
to me like she misses like some of the
good part oh I'm sorry I don't even care
about the thing I was just gonna have to
say Joshua Jackson like oh my god yeah
clean black hole Lockhart literally like
look so ugly in the show but I don't
care to me he's the most handsome man on
earth and I can't believe that him and
Diane Kruger like didn't work out but
now he's like so happy and in a
relationship and I'm really happy for
him but he is just so hot like no I love
him and it's crazy that the four kids
not only look like siblings but look
like the children of of Reese
Witherspoon and Colo card you know they
should have had if she wanted to get
into acting this would've been a great
role for one of races dog evil a should
be Alexa's she they cut off her hair
100% yeah that would be cool no but they
get like the 90s like fashion the music
so right like the cars the everything
like it's really they did a really good
job with all that we don't get a lot of
like 90
content so it's like you don't even
remember what the 90s felt like so
you're watching the show and it's like
oh yeah it's like we thought we were
like so I'm like cutting edge of
technology phones in our car yeah but
it's like it's so when you look at it
now it's like oh god how retro also but
things haven't changed that much because
I really forget most of the time that
it's not taking place right now until
they say something like oh she
friendzone to you did I just make up
friendzone yeah we're like I'm gonna be
like I'm dressed up as the first black
president Bill Clinton like obviously no
it was Obama but that hadn't happened
yet yeah so I think the show like it
does a good job of capturing the 90s but
not making it so much about that like
honestly forget forget sometimes ya know
I I totally agree I like the show a lot
I like the cast I think it's good I need
more episodes honestly one episode this
week was like kind of [ __ ] ish I'm
not gonna lie yeah they just like add so
much when it's a show like this like the
whole book club thing like never
happened
yeah but then when I thought that scene
was gonna be a turning point it's really
Mia yeah Mia and Reese like I thought it
was gonna be a major moment like where
they really became like you know they
were two different women with two
different stories but they're both
mothers and they're both women and I
thought it was really gonna like become
this like empowering female friendship
moment but I guess that's just nothing
like not at all what happens he's not at
home like not even close but I just love
Linda to be honest oh you do yeah yeah
we get to know her a lot more in the
show that in known in the book and in
the book I she was just like me I mean
her story's like so sad yeah I'd really
like me because I'm putting a face to
her and also when I was reading the book
like I knew that Reese played Elena and
that Kerry Washington played Mia so like
those were the faces I had and everyone
else I didn't even bother to think about
like Linda yeah but they're just a part
in the show that can be such a pit like
is he being at Mia's house him smoking
the pot like now twice in a row it's
never a thing and like oh yeah no Mia
was like not smoking in her house and
her kids were using her drugs like that
was not a thing they're really making
Kerry Washington like out to be the
worst possible mother
yeah person like human it really wasn't
so bad it's like so funny like pauses
like not a big deal now but like in the
90s like you do drugs in your house no
but still like if a mother has drugs
lying around her house and the
fourteen-year-old kids are doing it like
I even though pot is like cooler now I'm
still not okay I'm gonna be a no from me
yeah that that I just love josh magette
San like I can't get over that he's like
in the show
he's like a relevant but I love it
yet no but he's actually more relevant
in the show than in the book like in the
book he's just like dad walking in now
no but I guess in the in the book just
is he come out to the dad in the book is
he's not gay
oh yeah they like she at least not maybe
it was like a read between the lines
sort of thing but she wasn't well I
really like the show and I'm looking
forward to more episodes coming out
thanks Hulu for taking forever
we really don't appreciate it yeah I
mean actually I did last night when I
had to watch like four hours where he's
like oh my god it's last one so I really
recommend unorthodox but that's not our
official assignment our official
assignment is head over heels starring
Freddie Prinze jr. we'll find out where
it's available on we'll let you guys
need an unorthodox will be for next
weekend series yeah it's really like
apparently we have a lot more time yeah
we gonna do this till the end of
quarantine I really hope not
okay good say maybe we'll start to do
like every other day yeah even though
like what the [ __ ] else are we doing I
don't know but like every time we have
to watch something I'm like oh I have to
stop what I'm doing it's never work
whatever I was doing that was so fast is
there anything on tonight
it's Monday now so what's a current TV
schedule just so you know what maybe
we'll assign movies on the days where
there's not something we're watching so
like tomorrow we have an or pump role so
maybe I don't want to sign Wednesday we
don't have anything ever since jerseys
off Thursday's Kardashians and New York
well if there's gonna be great yeah so
maybe we'll do Monday Wednesday Friday
that's good all right well we'll see
well anything else you wanna say before
we let the people go it's ready one
o'clock you guys now it's really time
for lunch
Wow let's go have lunch thank you guys
for watching millennium or should we go
I'm gonna do Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time you're also available as a podcast
anywhere you get podcasts iTunes card
public radio so out of five anywhere you
get your podcast please leave a comment
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we have one job tomorrow
terrible job those graters excellent but
you did say 10:31 we're going live at
noon okay just week until further notice
probably next week to let us know what
you think about it unless you don't like
it then I don't want to hear your
feedback um we love you guys so much
have a great day stay home stay safe eat
good in the neighborhood
we'll see you tomorrow bye